Good morning.
I'm going to talk today about turning
points and on Thursday about turning
points and beyond that
probably about turning points,
but let me lay out right now
my own sort of selective list,
short list of the most important
turning points in the civil war.
Make the list and then we
will come back to them.
Now this is any military historians
or any civil war historians,
guests of course,
but uh,
there's no question that the Antietam
campaign of 1862 is a major turning point
in the civil war and I'll
select that as my first.
There are things happening before
that that are terribly important,
like the saving of Richmond against
Mcclellan's peninsula campaign in June,
July of 62 but it is this first
invasion of the north by Robert E.
Lee culminating in the bloodiest
single day of the civil war,
over 5,000 dead,
23,000 casualties in eight hours on fields
along a little creek in south western
Maryland that not only stopped this first
major invasion of the north and this
threat of a southern
army to northern soil,
northern resources and northern cities.
But it of course resulted in
Lincoln's emancipation proclamation,
which transformed the purpose of
the war on both sides. Back to that,
and the second,
the second major turning point in the war,
militarily I'd argue as most people do,
was the battle of Gettysburg and July of
1863 and the day after the three day's
battle at Gettysburg,
the bloodiest encounter of the entire war.
If you add up the three days casualties
of almost 56,000 dead and wounded in
three days,
that invasion of the not that battle of
course stopped least second invasion of
the north. And we'll come to that in
a moment, at least in brief terms.
On the day after tickets charge
at Gettysburg on the 4th of July,
the kind of citadel and river
town or city of Fredericksburg,
excuse me,
Vicksburg,
Mississippi fell to union forces
after a siege of nearly six months.
When grant took Vicksburg and the 4th of
July in 1863 it virtually opened up the
entire river to union control cut
geographically the confederacy in half.
It isolated Arkansas,
Louisiana,
and Texas from the rest
of the confederacy.
It was without a question at
least in long in the longterm,
a decisive turning point
in the war in the west.
Okay.
A third major turning point I'd argue
is the fall of Atlanta in September,
1864 and we'll come back to
that later on after the break.
A fourth major turning point in the
war politically without any question,
I think is the election of 1864 the only
time in modern history that a republic
attempted the whole day,
general election in the midst of
civil war and succeeded in doing it.
The reelection of Lincoln in 1864 was
absolutely crucial to the prosecution of
the war to the ends is the Lincoln
administration at least by then had
determined to fight it,
but without the fall of Atlanta
first week of September,
1864 is not at all clear.
Lincoln would have been reelected and
more on that later. And then fifth,
you could argue,
I would argue the greatest single turning
point in the civil war deeply related
to these military battle.
Front affairs is emancipation.
The emancipation of 4.2 million American
slaves in the midst of eventually all
out near total war by the north on the
south to destroy southern society and its
institutions transformed American history
more than just transforming a war.
Okay?
That's the theme of this lecture and
Thursday's lecture and even to some extent
beyond
it is those results beyond the battlefield
that ultimately it is our obligation
to understand.
It's important.
It's an obligation to understand why
the battle of Antietam turned the way it
did and it's an obligation done.
Just stay on why Lee is invading the
northwest second time in 1863 and why or
that encounter at Gettysburg
turned out the way it did,
but by then it is a war being fought
for something very different and much,
much larger than I had been at the outset.
One way into this story is
a very simple quotation.
In one of those interviews held with
former slaves and the WPA oral history
narratives in the 1930s these were the
interviews over 3000 of them done with
slaves. Many of them in their
eighties some even in their nineties
a guy named Cornelius Garner was
interviewed in 1937 at age 91
he was asked if he had fought in the
civil war and Cornelius replied to his
interviewer, who was the black
interview or in this case,
did I fight in the war? Well, if I hadn't,
you wouldn't be sitting there within,
you wouldn't be sitting
there right in that me today.
He then went on to describe a
corner of his native Norfolk,
Virginia were slave auctions used
to be conducted on New Year's Day.
That day,
New Year's Day said,
Garner should be kept by
all the colored people.
That is the day of freedom and day,
and they ought to remember Frederick
Douglass to Frederick Douglass told Abe
Lincoln give to black man
guns and let him fight.
And a Blinken say,
if I give him a gun
when it come to battle,
he might run in Frederick Douglass
say triumph and you'll win the war.
And Abe said, all right, I'll try them.
Oh,
that's a simplistic homespun
explanation for emancipation came about.
Oh, 180,000 African Americans
will end up in the union armies.
But old Cornelius Cornelius
wasn't entirely wrong.
All right.
Back to Virginia in 1862,
I'll put the outline backup if we need it.
Yeah.
Uh, I don't know if you can see all of
that, but I hope you can see some of it.
I left you with
Mcclellan's army on the
peninsula having been defeated.
I thought I'd show you a couple of
magnificent Matthew Brady photographs.
Photography of course
finally come into its own.
The civil war would be the first major
event in world history to be photographed
on a large scale. And it's in part
what made Ken Burns film possible,
especially the use of that camera.
They now have the can go into an old,
the girl type,
which isn't any bigger than this and
make it seem like a giant panorama.
This is a photograph taken
behind union troops overlooking,
um,
the Cumberland River and May, 1862.
That's before the, of the seven days.
That's during the march by
Mcclellan's army up the peninsula.
This is this.
I don't know how well you can see that,
but that's an absolutely stunning
photograph of a union wagon train.
I one of these,
a makeshift bridges.
They would build these things in
a few hours over all these rivers,
which in May of 1862
were flooding constantly.
It's union troops crossing.
Um,
the Chickahominy river
just east to Richmond,
May,
1862.
Now what happened next of
course was in a Zuora. I left.
You was least fateful decision to
not stay in, just defend Richmond.
So not just leave the war in central
Virginia having defeated or held back
Mcclellan's army and with a certain
degree of confidence in McAllen probably
would be McClellan and not move.
He decided to invade the north.
Now other, we're a high, you know,
all these high level councils of war
and Richmond between Jefferson Davis,
Lee and his generals.
There are arguments for and against it.
But Lee won the day in the argument
and he went West behind the Blue Ridge
mountains and invaded the north through
the upper part of the Shenandoah valley.
The goal of which was to not
attack Washington DC by any means.
I think I have a better map possibly.
Hm.
Yeah.
Maybe that helps a little better not to
attack Washington or necessarily to even
threaten Philadelphia directly.
Lee had no intention of taking
over in the northern cities.
He couldn't do that in other resources,
and I'm an army big enough.
How would he have occupied them?
But what he most wanted to do,
the aim of this invasion was wanting to
take the war out of ravaged Virginia two
to threaten northern cities,
especially the US Capitol
three to try to bring about,
and Great Britain was
on the brink of this,
and I'll come back to that foreign
policy diplomatic story a bit later,
but Great Britain was truly on
the brink of near recognition,
at least a kind of quasi
recognition of the confederacy.
And the theory here was
that as a confederate forces
could win a major victory
somewhere on northern soil,
get into Pennsylvania,
do it twice over live off the land,
possibly even forced
evacuation of the US Capitol.
That news of that in Great Britain might
bring about British recognition of the
confederacy is a legitimate government
and especially give the confederacy
access to its navy,
if not even the possibility
of ground forces.
And by the way,
a British force had already been
sent to Canada in early 1862 for the
possibility of intervention
in the American civil war.
Okay.
Now, there was also a theory here at
work that it's going to be dead wrong.
Lee believed, as did other confederate
leaders, that in Maryland in particular,
there was a great deal of confederate
sympathy and sentiment and a lot of young
Maryland men.
The theory was eager to
join the confederate forces
if they could just get out
of Maryland and that marching confederate
army was going to attract them.
At least that was the theory.
The problem was
when young men actually
saw that confederate army
there were appalled because
that confederate army then invaded
a across the Potomac river.
They cross the Potomac on September
four and September 5th 80 62 was an army
that had apparently remarkable,
almost miraculous morale.
They were winners.
They adjust,
defeated a union army with
Mcclellan's whole force,
whole force still back on the peninsula.
The 40 to 50,000 union troops
still guarding Washington DC.
We're decisively,
horribly defeated in the battle of second
Manasses the last two days of August
29th and 30th of 1862 that
union army retreated once again,
fought on the same fields
as first bull run, 15, uh,
of 13 months earlier retreated
in the Washington DC, Washington,
DC on September 1st,
1862 it was like a giant field hospital.
There were some three to 4,000 wounded
union soldiers all over the streets of
Washington.
Broken army with Mcclellan's army.
Now retreating back up the Chesapeake
and the Potomac and this huge flotilla
trying to get to Washington in case
Lee actually attacked Washington,
but the army Lee had was starving.
They weren't very well fed and
they weren't very well clad.
Here's one description of a young
Marylander who saw the confederate army.
He said it was nothing but quota set a
ragamuffins. It seemed as this every,
it seemed as if every cornfield and
Maryland had been robbed of a scare.
Crow is not Hannah,
none had any underclothing.
My costume consisted of a
ragged pair of trousers.
This guy apparently join a stained
dirty jacket and old slouch hat.
The brim tend up with a thorn a bit grim.
The blanket over my shoulder,
a grease smeared cotton have
sack full of apples and corn,
a cartridge box full and a musket.
I was barefoot.
It it had a stone bruise on each foot.
There was no one there who would not
have been run in by the police had he
appeared on the streets of a normal city.
There's plenty of testimony in the record
that a lot of young Maryland man came
out to see this. Now,
famous army of Robert E.
Lee took one look or one smell is one
put it and went back to their farms.
Lee will get almost no real
recruits out of Maryland.
What they will do in Maryland, however, is
capture several hundred slaves
and return them or take them to Virginia.
They're going to do the same thing in
1863 and the Gettysburg campaign on an
even larger scale.
Kidnapping was also part of
the confederate army's job.
Now the battle would not have occurred
at Antietam except for the famous,
and it's true. Last order.
Here's what happened.
Lee went into Maryland. The Union
army is all around Washington DC.
There's really no union army
up in Maryland to stopping yet.
He divided his army in three parts,
three core about 20,000 roughly men
each and they were spread out around
Maryland, about 20 miles
apart over a 60 mile stretch.
Stonewall. Jackson's core was sent to
Harper's ferry. The other two core,
they were separated at least
by 20 miles in between them.
These three parts of his army.
One of the cardinal rules of the old
manuals they were taught in at west point
was in the old, uh, in honorees.
Germany's a coat,
a military manual of conduct.
It said never divide your forces
and the presence of the enemy.
It's exactly what Lee had done.
The problem was that the union
command was about find out quickly,
Lee wrapped orders around three cigars
and his courier out to the three corps
commanders over the course of
more than a day to deliver.
The orders with the orders were lost
and they were found by a private in an
Indiana regiment whose name
was BW Mitchell, the 27th,
Indiana volunteers to be exact,
who picked up this bundle of three
cigars with paper wrapped around it.
And he read the orders and at
the bottom it said our ele.
And he apparently said something like,
I've heard of him.
And Lee was already a kind of budding
legend because of the seven days and
because of second Manassas.
And he gave it to his colonel who gave
it to his brigadier general who quickly
gave it to other generals.
Lincoln had little choice but
to put Mcclellan back in charge.
His commander at Second
Manassas had been, uh, uh,
a general named John Pope would've been
thoroughly defeated and it had a nervous
breakdown.
Seriously.
He had a mental breakdown during the
second Manassas battle and pope was out of
action to say the least, and he would
have been put out of action anyway.
It's only can put some calling back
in command in Washington DC and within
hours, Mcclellan was
delivered. Lee's orders.
This is though there had been a fourth
cigar from McClellan claw clothing.
Looked at these orders.
Um,
but they were discovered by the way,
on the 13th of September of
[inaudible] 62 we call them,
read them by that night.
The orders were basically to have all
parts of Lee's army concentrate rather
slowly but concentrate toward
the area of Sharpsburg Maryland,
which is right here alone in Tetum creek.
Sharpsburg is a little town Tatum's,
a little river,
but they were to congregate there
within the next three to four days.
Mcclellan now has at his
command about 90,000 troops.
If he marched them quickly.
He had the opportunity to
defeat Lee's army in parts,
but Mcclellan was McClellan.
He sat on the loss daughter for about
two days before he decided whether one
whether to believe it
to what to do about it.
Lee quickly discovered that his orders
never reached his commanders and he
worried.
He sent out new orders to concentrate
as fast as possible near Sharpsburg.
Mcallen finally moved slowly from
the camps around Washington up toward
Sharpsburg.
They encountered each other at
a place called South Mountain.
At the end of the day of
the 15th of September,
1862 and a battle of a
sort was fought there.
It was only a rear guard sort of thing.
Lee retreated out of that South Mountain
pass down into this little valley
around Sharpsburg Maryland,
which is just above the Potomac river.
And Ali was taking a tremendous risk here
because one of those other rules that
had been taught was never engage an enemy,
at least in full force with
a major river behind you.
That's exactly what happened.
They fought the battle of
Antietam and September 17th, 1862,
as I already said,
the bloody single day of the war.
They fought and cornfields if
fought across open fields. Um,
they fought along a sunken road.
Uh,
they fought along a famous bridge
now known as the Burnside bridge.
I have a couple of
photographs to show you.
They fought along what's known
as the Hagger's town road,
which along which 48 hours after the
battle won a Matthew Brady's photographers
took this
awful photograph.
Okay,
these are confederate dead. And
along that road there are many,
many photographs taken.
It emptied them.
This was another one of union dead lined
up for burial align dead probably 75
yards long
and Tim was in no way necessarily a
decisive or strategic
victory for either side.
I want you to see this
photograph because of it's irony.
You've probably seen this one before.
At the end of the day at Antietam,
there were about 23,000 casualties
on both sides, over 5,000 dead.
Then you may remember back on nine 11 and
the weight and the immediate aftermath
of nine 11 the estimates were over
5,000 dead at the World Trade Center and
people were comparing this to Antidem
as the bloodiest day of sacrifice in
American history. It turned out not
to be the case and nevertheless,
um,
what happened in the wake of Antietam
was it Lee Lee's of invasion of the north
had been stopped.
Now Mclellan missed a tremendous
opportunity to, to press the day,
and this has always been a debate among
military historians and you can read,
Oh God,
hundreds of pages on this if you care to.
It's always been a debate as to whether
if Mcclellan and followed this up,
could he have literally crushed Lee's
army with the Potomac at his back and in
effect ended the war.
There's surely was that possibility,
but the the day at Antietam had been
so devastating to both forces that
Mcclellan did not move. In
fact, he did not move for days.
It's also true though,
that Mcclellan kept in reserve
at Antietam and it was this act,
I think more than anything else.
It got Lincoln finally to go out there
by October 3rd and fire McClellan.
Mcclellan kept about 20,000 of
his troops in reserve at Antietam.
Always fearing that he was outnumbered.
He didn't use them
in a military sense at someone like
grant Bennet in charge it in Tetum.
It is entirely possible.
Lee would have been defeated
and at least the war in the east ended,
but that was not the case.
We retreated back into
Virginia to fight again.
This is a Matthew Brady
photograph taken of Lee,
of of Lincoln meeting with
Mcclellan Mcclellan right here.
There's also a famous photo of
them sitting in that same tent.
You may have seen burns
uses it in the series.
It was in this meeting that Lincoln went
out to meet with Mcclellan to urge him
to move to,
to push into northern Virginia to push
after Lee's army and early autumn or the
weather was so good and
Mcclellan did not move,
and a couple of days
after that he was fired
and fired for good. All on Mcclellan
will not leave history. Of course,
he will come back to be the Democratic
Party's candidate for president in 1864
against Abraham Lincoln.
Now it is of course in the
wake of Antietam that Lincoln
issued his emancipation
proclamation.
Let me turn to that now and explain
why and how emancipation became
the new cause of the war.
Now
let's discuss Lincoln for a moment.
First,
the biggest problem with Abraham
Lincoln has always been not a,
that isn't how we interpret him,
treat him, understand him, use him,
which we do constantly.
Every president,
every American politician,
as David Donald once said famously in
the 1950s has to get right with Lincoln.
Everybody uses it.
We twist him all inside out and make
them say whatever we want them to say.
And there's no American,
no other American in our history who has
been given credit for more apocryphal
quotations and Abraham Lincoln
a little later in the course.
I'll use a few of them at the end of
when we get to the end of the war.
But the problem with Lincoln
is indeed his ambiguity,
the reality of his historical ambiguity.
There is a puzzling dualism about him.
There are two,
at least two seemingly
incompatible legends,
if you want about Abraham Lincoln.
One has him as the kind of
awkward storytelling rails,
splitting front tier folk hero,
everybody's favorite homespun granddaddy
with a corncob pipe who might just tell
you a little raunchy story.
Okay.
And have you chuckling?
He's kind of, you know, fun.
Okay.
The other though is the towering
political genius, the moral leader,
the shaper of a nation's Destiny's
savior of the union and the great
emancipator.
I ain't never quite
asked for any of those.
Everybody needs to claim him though.
There's a brilliant essay on this by a
historian named Scott Sandage came out
about 10 years ago.
It's called a marble house divided.
It's all about the Lincoln Memorial.
A lot of you've probably
been to the Lincoln Memorial.
It is America secular temple.
Everybody uses it.
The Ku Klux Klan is held at
rallies at Lincoln's temple. Uh,
Martin Luther King gave the
dream speech at Lincoln's Temple.
It's been used by every extreme of,
of American political culture.
If you want to claim
the nation's attention,
go to the nations temple and
claim all day. But behind you,
he was never very open about himself.
Never wrote an autobiography or didn't
write many autobiographical sentences.
As a matter of fact,
didn't live long enough to do that.
He was never an abolitionist.
He actually had a lot of personal
contempt for radical abolitionist.
He didn't like a lot of their arguments
and he didn't like their tactics and
strategies.
He was a genius with language on.
And there's no question about that.
We've never had a president
who could use words,
who could find the music
of words like Lincoln.
He wrote every word and every sentence
of every one of his speeches and every
one of his great public letters,
Jim Macpherson,
every once so far as to write an article
saying how Lincoln won the war with
metaphors.
I don't know whether a metaphor can when
you were war strongest battalions might
be a little more important in the end.
Who knows?
Is he the symbol?
Oh,
a man who held back emancipation as a
white supremacist or is he the symbol of
the man who outgrew his prejudices and
those of his time to become the amounts
of pater.
Oh,
was he just the shrewd politician kind
of finding the middle ground and seeing
how the wind was going to blow if you
tried this or if he threw up that balloon
or if he tried that?
No.
There are many ways to reflect on Lincoln.
My own favorite expression about
him and thousands of these,
my own favorite comes from Web Dubois,
the great black scholar of the 20th
century who I think really captured all
sides of Lincoln in one quotation.
Yeah.
This was two boys and an editorial.
He wrote in 1922 in the crisis magazine.
He wrote it at the time of the
unveiling of the Lincoln Memorial.
He also wrote it at a time when he was
fed up with all of the national honoring
and celebration of Robert E.
Lee.
So it may have been that
that celebration of Lee,
which disgusted Dubois may have had
something to do with how he wrote this
expression about Lincoln.
This was Dubois on Lincoln quote.
I love him.
Not because he was perfect,
but because he was not
perfect and yet triumphed.
There was something left
so that at the crisis,
he was big enough to be inconsistent,
cruel,
merciful, peace, loving a fighter,
despising negroes and
letting them fight and vote,
protecting slavery and freeing slaves.
He was a man,
a big inconsistent,
brave man.
Okay.
I'd argue my friends that, uh, the, the
most important thing you can grasp it,
but Abraham Lincoln is that he
had the capacity for growth.
He was big enough to be inconsistent,
okay.
Or as Emerson once put it,
consistency is the Hobgoblin
was simple minds number,
all that language about flip flopping.
And the 2004 election,
one of the candidates was alleged to have
been a flip flopper all the time. Well,
if Abraham Lincoln hadn't
been a flip flopper,
we wouldn't have had the emancipation
proclamation. So here's the flip flopping.
Lincoln's early record on
slavery is interesting,
is early as 1837 he was one of only
two representatives in the Illinois
legislature to vote against the
resolution declaring the right of slave
ownership.
He was 28 years old at that time.
Okay.
Is One two year term in the House
of Representatives during that term,
which was a Mexican war,
he found himself appall that the
slave trade district of Columbia,
you could go visit slave auctions.
As I said before, I think two,
three blocks down the street
from the capitol. He called
that slave market quota,
sort of Negro lived livery stable.
We're droves of Negroes
are collected temporarily.
Captain finally taken to southern
markets precisely like droves of horses.
Okay.
He also sat during that same term.
If the Negro is a man,
why then my ancient faith teaches me
that all men are created equal and that
there can be no moral rights in
connection with one man's making,
a slave of another.
Yeah.
At the same time,
Lincoln though was a Henry Clay wig.
He was a supporter of the compromise
of 1850 he believed in compensation,
the slave owners as a way,
a hope of setting up some kind
of gradual emancipation plan
and he believed as Henry Clay
had founded it and this idea,
at least he did for a while.
This idea of colonization
of sending blacks either to
Africa or to the Caribbean
or to Central America.
I don't have time to stop on the those
fabulous Lincoln Douglas debates where
you can find every extreme of Abraham
Lincoln. I was once given an assignment,
you know, junior seminars
and undergraduate, oh,
Fred Williams at Michigan state sent us
to the Lincoln collected papers and he
said,
your assignment is to come back with one
passage demonstrating that Lincoln was
antislavery on believing in emancipation
and come back with one passage.
Just showing that he
was a white supremacist,
not growing up a Lincoln
lover. And I thought, oh dear,
that's like, you know, you've been raised
in a certain religion and somebody says,
go read the Bhagavad Gita or you know,
read the Koran or study
Buddhism for Awhile.
I did that too for a while.
I didn't learn much. But,
and sure enough, you find all of those
extremes in the Lincoln Douglas debates.
We also know of course that he was a
free soiler and he's most famous in the
south of course,
for that language of putting slave around
a course of ultimate extinction in a
house divided speech and elsewhere.
But once the war came,
yeah,
the imperative about what to do about
slavery was a huge indelicate and terrible
political question.
And this is the link and that
will be forever debate it.
And there'll be debated next year like,
like it's never been debated cause it's
the bicentennial, it was birth next year.
And as I've warned you,
it will be raining Lincoln books
and you will have to dodge them
next year
now after the war broke out.
Yeah,
immediately. Some slaves began
to come in to union lines,
the first word this a,
a Ford and Florida.
Okay.
And then as early as May,
1861,
some slaves began to come in
to union lines, handfuls, uh,
near Fortress Monroe in Virginia.
And there was a union command,
or they're a political general,
a former Democrat before the war and
anything but an abolition is Benjamin F.
Butler, who never the loss
will. Nevertheless, when the
slaves came into his lines,
he realized, no, wait a sec,
the confederates are over
there using these people to
build their fortifications.
Maybe we could use them to
bill are fortifications.
So why don't we confiscate
them and him contraband of war,
their property under law call contraband
and the name stuck of course know that
name will end up in poetry and
song and even in the law or to
contraband property.
Okay.
But at the outset of the war
in the summer of 61 fall,
winter 61 62 into the spring of 62,
the first year of the war,
the official policy of the
Lincoln Administration and
of the Union forces across
the land, the official policy
was called denial of asylum.
It meant that any slave who
escaped into union lines,
the officer in charge and command of that
unit have the responsibility to return
that slave to his owner.
If the owner,
this was the impossible kicker,
if the owner was loyal to the union,
if that owner was not loyal to the union,
it was in the confederate
army or something, then yes,
you could admit that slave to
your lines as contraband of war.
No,
of course.
If this had only been a trickle of people
here and they're coming in to union
lines, possibly this could be
enforced, but it wasn't enforceable.
How's that union command are going to
go out and figure out, uh, Hey, uh,
Mr. Enslaved person is your own
or loyal or disloyal to the union,
that slave, it's probably going to say
he's a confederate. What do you think?
Of course,
most were.
Now,
Congress took the lead before Lincoln
ever wrote an emancipation proclamation.
Although Lincoln was thinking
about this and working on this,
all through that summer of
1862 congress took the lead.
Now this was a congress. Remember that
is now dominated by the Republican Party.
You got an 11 southern states out of
the union. They don't have any centers.
I don't have any. I remember is
in the House of Representatives.
This is a northern Republican majority,
a significant majority.
Now they're going to run into
trouble in the, in the fall,
congressional elections of 1862 and
they're gonna lose some of those seats
because of what they're doing.
Now,
Congress took the lead pastor an article
of war in March of 1862 which said,
fugitive slaves must be
admitted to union camps.
It didn't say what their status would be.
It didn't define anybody.
I left illegal status vague. It
just said, any escaped slave,
Masa now be admitted.
Now,
the reason they did that is because
this denial of asylum policy had caused
chaos and a lot of union units.
Brief example.
Remember this guy, Charles Brewster,
whose letters I read from the other day,
this guy from Massachusetts, his
letters I edited and so on. Well,
Charley Brewster, this racist
from North Hampton, Massachusetts,
28 years old by now.
Nevertheless,
in late fall of 1861 he took a runaway
slave who was 17 years old and named
David into his, uh,
personal care.
He made him his personal servant.
This is after Brewster.
God has commissioned as an officer.
He even wrote home to
his sister several times,
asking the sister to send stocking
caps, socks, and old pair of pants.
He even named the shirts that
he wanted to put on his David.
It was as though he was dressing him.
And Brewster was a determined never
to send that kid back to slavery.
But down came the orders by January,
early February,
1862 that all fugitive slaves within
their camps must be returned to their
owners if those owners came to
the union lines to retrieve them.
And the future of named David had
his owner waiting at the camp.
There was a near mutiny
and the 10th Massachusetts,
which was Brewster's regimen between
those soldiers who wanted to protect these
fugitive slaves and free them
in effect and those who did not,
and that's the one on in
hundreds of regiments.
Brewster's Brewster was threatened with
court martial and being run out of the
army if he didn't give
back this fugitive slave.
His compromise was it.
He took it as this young David out into
the woods and he said, get Outta here,
run.
I'll just tell him you ran away,
and that's what he did.
By that Spring, Congress decided any
fugitive slave was sketch to union lines.
It must be accepted.
In April of 1862 congress
on the 16th of April,
and this was a very significant law.
They passed abolition, the end of
slavery and the District of Columbia.
They gave $300 per slave and compensation
to those owners of slaves in the
district.
The district of Columbia
in 1862 had 3,100 slaves.
They also put,
I think the figure was about $300,000
in that bill where they provided for the
possible colonization of blacks
voluntarily to foreign countries.
As a result of emancipation,
a policy of the Lincoln
administration now was supporting.
Okay.
Then third and June,
in June of 62 congress by majority vote
sort of through a great deal of American
history on the dust heap,
and they abolished slavery forever
and the Western territories,
arguably the single most important cause
of the civil war stroke of the pen.
In June of 62 they ended slavery in
spite of the dred Scott decision.
Now remember what the dred Scott decision
had said here was congress passing a
law in direct opposition to
a supreme court decision.
That's an argument for not having
too many civil wars, you see,
because Congress might end up doing
anything in the midst of the civil war and
they surely did here.
And then finally on July 17th,
congress passed what was called
the second confiscation act.
There'd been a first confiscation act
pass back in August of 61 even in the
first confiscation. I can. By the way,
these were acts authorizing union forces
to confiscate confederate property.
Even in the first re confiscation act
back in August of [inaudible] 61 slaves
were mentioned as property.
They're status was still very vague,
but in the second confiscation act,
July 62 the law explicitly
freed slaves of all persons,
quote in rebellion anywhere,
any slave of anyone
supporting the confederacy.
It did everything. The emancipation
proclamation will later do,
and then soon it was in some ways more
extensive because it included all parts
of the south, including
those border states that did
not seceded from the union.
Now,
well, Congress already having done
these things by July of 62 by the way,
this is all during the peninsula campaign
down in Virginia.
Second confiscation act was passed in
the immediate wake of the seven days
battle.
Lee is deciding to
invade the North Lincoln.
As you may know the story, if you've
read team of rivals by Doris Goodwin,
you know it would hang
out at the war department.
He'd go there for some solitude.
He had private little office there.
He began to draft an emancipation
proclamation as a legal brief,
a legal document. He kept it in a locked
door, have a desk at the war department.
Supposedly there was one or
two guards that knew about it,
not sure about that,
but he was beginning to draft
an emancipation proclamation
probably as early as
June,
certainly by July of 62
yeah,
the pressure now monitor
from every direction.
He's secretly held meetings with the
delegation of Delaware and a delegation
from Kentucky trying to convince them
to institute gradual emancipation plans
over time with compensation
to slave owners that would,
that would free slaves
over a 35 year period.
This was Lincoln, the gradual, this,
this was Lincoln trying to condition
public opinion, Delaware. At that point,
I only had 1800 slaves were far more
slaves in the district of Columbia.
Then the war and all of Delaware,
but the Delaware delegation that came
to the White House to meet with Lincoln
told him unequivocally no,
they weren't going to touch
slavery for fear of what it might
ignite.
Lincoln waited and waited.
He was attacked by Horace Greeley and
the New York Herald Tribune. As you know,
read the famous Greeley letter
and the Johnson collection.
This is the famous passage in August
of 62 or Lincoln said, I will free the,
I will save the union by
freeing all the slaves,
or I will save the union by
freeing none of the slaves.
My aim in the end is to say that,
yeah,
but read that entire letter.
Not just that quote.
I'm going to leave that to you.
Read the entire letter because he's
actually honest on both sides of the
semicolon.
Look for his semi colon
and judge both sides.
He's a crafty cat.
You got to read them closely.
Lincoln needed a battlefield victory.
He needed some kind of battlefield
success and he gets that of course,
with Antidem
in the wake of Antietam,
five days afterward,
22nd September 62 Lincoln issued the
preliminary emancipation proclamation
that preliminary emancipation proclamation
said that slaves in the United States,
in the states, in
rebellion would be freed.
On January 1st
there was a carrot and a stick.
The stick was emancipation and conquest.
If the union forces could ever do it,
and the carrot was in effect,
he invited the confederate states to
throw down their arms, give up the war,
come back to the union
by January 1st
they're not going to it of course,
but
he was hoping or was he hoping?
Yeah.
I'm going to leave you with this.
Back in Virginia
was a young slave, 22 years old.
His name was John Washington.
He'd grown up in Fredericksburg.
Virginia had a white father.
I mean he never knew.
A slave mother named Sarah.
She taught him to read and write. He grows
up in urban slave with lots of skills,
highly valued,
probably a brilliant young man.
You gotta hire it out five times in the
late 1850s in the first year of the war,
he married his sweetheart and January,
1862 in the African Baptist
church in Fredericksburg,
and he chose his moment of escape at the
first appearance of union forces along
the Rappahannock river in
Fredericksburg on the 16th excuse me,
the 18th of April,
he left a narrative that he wrote
after the war that I had the great,
good fortune to have lopped in my lap
and have recently published a book about
it.
And in that narrative,
he tells this remarkable story
of the day of his escape.
He even drew a map of Fredericksburg
of the day of his escape,
including a glossary of 16 sites and
buildings and crossroads on that map as
though he wanted the world to
see as well as hear his story.
And John tells the story.
He's 22 years old.
He tells a story of all the white
people evacuating Fredericksburg and his
mistress. Mrs Talavera is literally
packing her China and her silver,
and she says, one day, now,
Johnny, you'll be with us tomorrow.
You'll be with us tomorrow. She's assuming
his loyalty. And he said, yes, Mrs. Yes,
Mrs. I'll be with you tomorrow.
And then his next scene is he's at a
hotel where he's been hired out as a
steward,
almost like an assistant manager.
Can you describe all the white people
fleeing the hotel and fleeing the streets
of Fredericksburg.
And he says he took the 12 workers up on
the roof of the hotel and the hotel was
called the Shakespeare.
I kid you not,
he takes all the black workers up on the
roof of the hotel where they could see
across the river and see what he called
the gleam of the Yankees bandits.
And then he brought them all back down
into the kitchen and he poured a round of
drinks
and he held a toast and the
toast was to the Yankees.
And he instructed his fellow workers,
he said to get out of there,
but he said,
don't get too far from the Yankees.
And then John Larson and walk
two blocks down to the river.
He witnessed the formal
surrender of Fredericksburg.
He saw the bridges being burned
by the confederate forces.
And he walked one mile up river and he
said he crossed the river at Ficklin,
his mill and the old stone
ruins of Miller is still there,
so I know exactly where he crossed
the river. He got into a rowboat.
He crossed and that night he slept in
the camp of the 30th New York volunteers,
a captain in that regiment named Ladd,
l a d d formerly freedom.
He said,
based on the law that had just been
passed by Congress 48 hours earlier in
Washington, freeing the slaves
in the district of Columbia.
John Washington spent the rest of that
summer as a campaign and a guide for the
Union army all the way
through second Manassas.
He dated his arrival in Washington
DC as part of the first great wave of
Friedman into the capitol as September 1st
and by the following year I found him
in a city directory record living at his
first address on 19th street
in Washington. He had his wife,
his newborn child,
his mother and his 68 year old
grandmother living there with him
apart from beneath next to underneath
this great military and political story.
Now thousands upon thousands
of John Washington's.
We're freeing themselves.